hey 42 here baby
puffins are called puff flings welcome
to RIT 11 of the 12 men who have walked
on the moon we're in the Boy Scouts
every month in the Netherlands 133
billion insects are killed colliding
into cars squirrels can remember the
hiding places of up to 10,000 nuts in
2011 cheese was the most stolen food in
the world during pregnancy some women
crave non edible items such as paper
clay and metal it's an eating disorder
known as pica a man from Florida was
arrested after calling 911 three times
asking the dispatcher if she was
interested in going on a date with him
gladiators sweat was used as a beauty
product for one skin in ancient Rome the
expiration date on bottled water is
actually for the bottle not the water
the most times a person has been stung
by bees without dying is 2443
dogs can smell where electric current
has bee and human fingerprints that are
a week old under the provisions of the
1912 Scottish protection of animals act
the Loch Ness monster is a protected
species the lion used in the original
MGM movie logo killed its trainer and
two assistants the day after the logo
sequence was filmed California consumes
more bottled water than any of a product
spiders are extremely carnivorous 10,000
spiders sealed in a room will eventually
result in one enormous leaf at spider
lava can flow as fast as a sprinting
Greyhound thanks for the view subscribe
for more thoughty2